The first trailer for Avengers: Infinity War
has already provided Marvel fans a ton of
clues about what's to come in the newest superhero
smash, featuring the old guard and the newcomers
working together to defeat Thanos.
But there are some aspects of the teaser that
might not be so obvious upon first review.
Let's take a look at some of the finer details
in Infinity War's first trailer that might
hold more significance than you think.
The hero hotline
When Tony Stark is shown visiting Doctor Strange's
Sanctum Sanctorum, there's an interesting
little Easter Egg contained in his hands:
the same cell phone that Steve Rogers gave
him at the tail end of Civil War.
Even though the two didn't completely resolve
their differences, Steve apologized for withholding
the truth about Bucky's assassination of Tony's
parents in a note that also read:
"I know you were only doing what you believe
in, and that’s all any of us can do, it’s
all any of us should.
So, no matter what, I promise you, if you
need us, if you need me, I'll be there."
Cap may be enjoying asylum in Wakanda, but
it's clear Tony's going to take him up on
that offer in Avengers: Infinity War once
the threat of Thanos becomes clear.
New shield
In the trailer, T'Challa the Black Panther
instructs:
"Get this man a shield."
He's talking, of course, about getting Steve
Rogers back into superhero action—and the
line also serves as a clever callback to the
characters' comics history.
In 1941, the Captain earned the trust of T'Challa's
father T'Chaka, who gave him a piece of Wakandan
vibranium —which was then used to help form
Cap's circular shield.
Decades later, when Rogers gave up the title
of Captain America in a dispute with the U.S.
government, he was gifted a new vibranium
shield by Black Panther.
Now a nomad?
Steve isn't the only one sporting a new appearance
in the trailer.
There's also a subtle difference in the way
Bucky is outfitted, as the star looks to be
missing from his new bionic arm.
Since it was lasered off of him by Tony Stark
in the same battle that cost Cappy his shield,
Bucky too might've decided to shed a piece
of his pre-Civil War identity and go forward
as a non-Winter Soldier nomad.
Has he rid his mind of all that pesky HYDRA
programming at long last?
Sebastian Stan has cast doubt on how well
that would work out for him, telling The Daily
Beast:
"I think Bucky represents some of those people
that come back and just don’t know how to
restart their lives."
A new Vision
In the first new glimpse we get of Vision
in Infinity War, he looks a lot more human
than he used to.
His appearance is almost ordinary, save for
the bright yellow stone embedded in his forehead.
In the comics, a defining feature of J.A.R.V.I.S.'s
post-download existence is that he wants to
be as human as possible.
So, the fact that he's now been able to shed
all the red -- at least for a while -- means
that either someone's fantasizing about what
might've been or he's figured out some way
to shapeshift into his desired reality.
In either case, he's clearly developed a romantic
relationship with the Scarlet Witch, which
is also a nod to a central component of his
comics origins.
The two have had quite a storied relationship
throughout the years — often tumultuous,
but also resulting in twins named Wiccan and
Speed, who both end up on Young Avengers during
their teenage years.
A certain casting call for Avengers 4 seems
to indicate that the latter part, at least,
will come to fruition.
Blondes have more fun?
Natasha Romanoff is another of the exiled
Avengers who's seen sporting a new look in
Infinity War's first-glimpse.
Rather than the dark auburn 'do that's been
her trademark all these years, she's shown
with blonde locks.
She's probably still a fugitive at the start
of this movie, and the hue of her 'do may
just be a simple effort to disguise herself
from the government.
However, some suspect it might also harken
back to the comics' second Black Widow character,
Yelena Belova, who sported similarly blonde
locks.
If she is just trying on a new identity for
size, why not make it her alter ego one plucked
from the page as a hat-tip to her comic fans?
Frozen in time?
Although we don't know for sure if Thanos
has or will be able to steal the Time Stone
from the Sanctum Sanctorum, there's at least
one shot in the trailer which hints that time
is being messed with in some way.
As Tony Stark is shown on the street, removing
his glasses in disbelief, the rest of his
friends seem to be left in a frozen state
behind him.
What's more is that those mystical shields
seem to be turning very slowly, if at all.
Does this mean that Thanos will get his hands
on that powerful green gem despite the heroes'
best efforts?
Or is Stark somehow commanding the Time Gem
in this scene?
Time...will tell.
Nick Fury the storyteller
Although we don't actually see him in the
trailer, we do get to hear Nick Fury's voice
chime in on the group storytelling project
that tells us how the Avengers came to be.
"There was an idea."
He's joined by other characters to finish
out the narrative, but his inclusion is important
because the phrase is an almost exact replica
of the speech he gave in the first Avengers
movie.
Samuel L. Jackson has said he will not appear
in Infinity War, Avengers 4 or Black Panther,
but could this be a sign that something's
changed?
If not, at least we know Fury will be there
in spirit.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!